So let's,
let's look at that user interface idea.
Obviously what happens when you're
looking at a computer screen is that the
complexity of the screen is reduced to a
set of icons that can serve as tools.
And I think that that's a reasonable way
of thinking about how we look at the
world
flex in it,
in that Hoffman's theory is that natural
selection didn't select our brains to,
to record an accurate representation of
reality.
Like the scientific model we'll attempts
to get ever closer to what reality is
really light.
No natural selection just wants us to
escape predators.
It doesn't matter what they look like,
what the icon is in your brain of
breaths,
that's brain or whatever,
as long as you survive,
that's all that matters.
So,
uh,
this is why we're so easily deceived by
illusions and magic tricks and things
like that,
that,
you know,
our brains aren't really wired to,
to represent reality as it really is.
Whatever that means.
And,
um,
yes,
I can say that without human
consciousness,
the iconic reality that we inhabit would
not exist.
Right.
Okay.
Did that slightly is that,
um,
is I told them so let's say,
uh,
you know,
what's it like to be a dolphin?
I don't know.
Okay.
So some kind of echolocation system.
So,
and his point is,
well there,
you know,
the sharks are dangerous,
so,
uh,
his,
they avoid charts.
But the question is what does a shark
look like in Dalton's brain versus what
it looks like in our brain?
It's probably quite different and I
really have no idea what a shark looks
like two adults,
but I do know this,
they're really our shirts and they
really have sharp things on one end and
a tail on the other and they're eating
machines and you should avoid them.
So yeah,
that's actually a weakness of the icon
claim I would say,
because it looks to me like here,
here's the twist on it.
What we see in our conscious experience
are functional icons,
but they're also low resolution
representations of the things that are
actually there.
And,
and I don't think that computer icons
are low resolution representations of
the things that are there.
They're just functional icons.
Now.
I might be wrong about that because,
because it's hard to to conjure up that
analysis on the fly.
But the Trashcan,
for example,
on your desktop is actually,
it's actually a low resolution
representations of an actual trashcan,
not a computer trashcan,
even though it functions the same way.
Right.
So,
so I think I liked the icon idea,
but I think it misses some element of
the actual relationship between the
perception and the reality.
We definitely see in low resolution,
which is why we can stand animated
pictures like say the Simpsons,
you know,
where,
where everything is one extremely low
resolution,
but that makes no functional difference
to us whatsoever.
And we definitely see and hear in low
resolution,
but the resolution like I think what we
see or something like instead of icons,
they're more like thumbnails that are
functional.
That's a good analogy.
Well,
I like it because the thumbnail,
the thumbnail actually is an unbiased
sampling of the actual object,
right?
Because a photograph is relatively
unbiased sample of an object and you can
compress it.
You can,
you can,
you can until it,
and what you're doing is blurring out
distinctions between,
you're blurring out distinctions between
different aspects of it without,
without losing the relationship between
the parts.
It's something like that.
Yeah,
that's right.
Yeah.
In a way,
much of science operates at a
metaphorical level,
you know,
that string,
have you ever seen a string theory
documentary that didn't have violins
featured in it?
You know,
that,
that the computer,
the brain is like a computer.
It's like a dual processor.
Yeah.
Because we have to talk and we have to
transfer the literal meaning of
metaphors to move something from here to
there in the original Greek.
So,
you know,
we tried to capture some idea that's
really hard to get that buy something
we're very familiar with.
So.